the head of the Nea National Education
Association one of these big teacher
unions This Woman's name is Rebecca
Pringle
she's a graduate of the University of
Pittsburgh that is the school of course
that tried to shut me down and at which
the libs tried to murder me somewhat
recently gives you a little a hint of
her intellectual formation and academic
background the Nea president has this to
say
about the future of American Education
I can hear Chase Seattle
crying out to us
urging us to remember
when you know who you are when your
mission is clear
and you burn with the inner fire of an
unbreakable will
no cold can touch your heart no values
can dampen your purpose and yay you are
those stars in the darkness your light
will not be dim your purpose will drive
you in our righteous fight for freedom
because you know who you are
now I know that we have a number of
viewers and listeners to this show in
Central Europe so I'll translate that
speech
and I ain't blushed and weak benign
I
don't usually make that sort of a
comparison but if you were only
listening to it
you just you can't fully appreciate how
this woman in some ways looks a little
different from a certain Austrian
painter and 20th Century political
leader but in other ways she's got the
short cropped hair she's gotten the
hands and the passion she even talks
about the will the will will win out our
Wills that are you suggesting a phrase
such as perhaps the Triumph of the
willow lady or are you it just
seems a little
over the top
and this woman
is a major leader of Education in
America
perhaps the best advertisement for
homeschooling I have ever seen as this
woman falls into an occult ecstasy
also yeah also kind of weird occult
ideas that the parallels between a
certain historical phenomenon that I I
don't usually compare things to and
these modern lives especially in
education quite striking and and so you
look at that and you say goodness
gracious this woman is has no control
over herself that's the point of
education is to control yourself is to
be brought up learn how to behave learn
how to discipline those those lower
passions and to bring them into a chord
with the rational will and also to know
things to this gets back to what we're
talking to at the top of the show from
that yes we have deceit and Corruption
and vice and all this nasty stuff in our
political order but but one of the
Lesser discussed consequences of that is
just sheer incompetence and you see this
expressed in our educational apparatus
the the teachers and the administrators
especially
broadly speaking cannot teach things
they can't teach math they can't teach
reading
they can't teach basic life skills
they go off in these Flights of Fancy
about whatever struggles this lady has
dealt with in her life but but they
can't they can't actually do the basic
elements of the job and you're seeing
this everywhere right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you are
hiring you're probably dealing with
economic uncertainty by definition now
more than ever it is important to hire
the right people faster and more
efficiently to keep overall costs down
thankfully zip recruiter is a hiring
partner that is focused on you and your
needs from pricing to technology
everything that zip recruiter does is
for you and what works best for you
right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com Knowles zip recruiters
smart technology identifies the best
matches for your job and lets you invite
candidates that you really want to apply
to your job before other businesses can
snag them I absolutely love how
straightforward their pricing is you
know what you pay for before posting
your job so you can stick to your budget
budget with no surprises hire the best
with the help of a partner that is all
about you with the zip recruiter four
out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day just go to
ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com Knowles
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
right now go to expressvpn.com Knowles
profiling surveillance and data
harvesting are a few things that you
probably don't like very much about the
tech Giants what can you actually do
about it when you rely on so many of
their products well the good news is
doesn't take much for you to take a
stand for less than seven bucks per
month you can join me and fight back
against big Tech by using expressvpn how
do you think big tech companies make all
their money anyway well by tracking your
searches video history and everything
you click on and then selling your
personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that is why expressvpn is
the only VPN that I use and Trust on all
of the devices to make it much more
difficult for them to exploit my data
for their own profits and the best part
is it's so easy even I can use it I'm a
bit of a Luddite you just click one
button on your phone on your computer on
your tablet turns it on keeps people out
of your business time to fight back go
to expressvpn.com Knowles get three
extra months for free expresvpn.com
expressvpn.com Knowles to learn more
goodness gracious there was a a
really pathetic story out of New York
New York City is paying two billion
dollars to black people
New York City specifically is paying two
billion dollars to black people who
performed poorly on an old teaching exam
Hispanic people too they wanted to
become teachers and they took this exam
and they failed and they sued and they
said this exam is racist and so they
didn't they didn't become teachers a lot
of them New York City is going to pay
two billion dollars to them
some people who never worked as a
teacher will get more than one million
dollars each
that they could even get pensions as a
result of this which will inflate the
cost beyond the 1.8 billion dollars that
the post is reporting 64 year old Herman
Grimm
will be paid 2 million fifty five
thousand three hundred eighty three
dollars after failing this test a lot
because supposedly the test was racist
this guy Hermann Grimm was asked how is
the test racist he couldn't say
he has no examples
he failed the test a lot he's probably
not good at coming up with answers here
but he is pretty good at making two
million bucks and you want to know the
cherry on top of this story
they remade the test
it's no longer racist the test now
totally woke liberal politically correct
Progressive racism free
the scores didn't improve
the the
black people performed poorly on that
exam too
why is that I don't know why you'll hear
some people say oh it's because black
people are terrible you might hear some
people say well it's because they the
the people who took this test they
didn't have a good educational
background they might say well they
didn't have a good social background and
so they just didn't have the ability to
prepare for this test in the same way
that other people did
know I don't know why the the Black and
Hispanic test takers didn't do as well
on the old test and the new test I don't
know it's not my particular subject area
of Interest I leave it to other people
to to figure it out here's the one thing
I do know
it
it wasn't because the old test was
racist we've now proven that because of
the new test
and yet two billion dollars from New
York City taxpayers still going to these
people
which is a reminder that we talk a lot
about reparations this is the new
radical liberal proposal is to resurrect
the idea of reparations for slavery
centuries after the fact but we have
reparations this is a type of
reparations this is a an expression of
how in the United States if you can
claim that something is racist you can
get whatever you want
this is why this kind of language is
bandied about this is why it's the worst
thing that you can possibly be called in
modern America is to be called a racist
it's why people throw it around totally
baselessly I remember David Webb the
black conservative commentator he was
hosting a radio show this is some years
ago now and a woman called in they were
debating an issue he was winning the
debate and she said well you only think
that because of your white privilege
it was a radio interview it was a phoner
so she didn't she didn't know and even
Webby says you know
I'm pretty sure it's not and I don't
think he would say that if we were on TV
right now and he totally got her but she
didn't care she just she just wanted
some excuse just like these people and I
guess good on them these people who just
got paid two billion dollars over
nothing
I guess good on him because they gained
the system
but that kind of a system is not going
to be able to persist forever in part
because it encourages selfishness and
pride and greed and vice and Corruption
among the people but also in part
because
we can't do the basic stuff that a
society is supposed to do because we've
we're lowering standards
needlessly because we can't teach we can
adjudicate teachers we can't
run the government we can't conduct
investigations we can't get the economy
to work we can't conduct foreign policy
we just can't do stuff from we can't
reason about these things
I keep going back to this and rotate
example
the fact that our moral discourse on the
right and the left has has boiled down
to this
significant But ultimately relatively
small question of hey do people consent
do those girls consent to be pimped out
by Andrew Tate well then it's it's
totally fine hey did do people consent
to all sorts of weird sex stuff in
America and including children oh then
it's totally fine isn't there something
a little bit deeper we used to have
moral discourse we used to have the
ability to reason about these things
as that
Ebbs away so Ebbs away our civilization
well cease to be civilized will become
barbarous materialists howling into the
wind
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure you subscribe ring that Bell
don't miss a single video here on the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel